[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv 78
bienvenue pour cette page d'actualités
locales et régionales tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 12 février
objectif à 2020 pour accorder l'ensemble
des foyers yvelinois la fibre optique
parmi les opérateurs qui travaillent en
ce sens orange le groupe doit déployer
le très haut débit dans les 102 communes
les plus denses du département le point
dans cette édition pour les villes de
saint quentin en yvelines et des
collégiens la rencontre de
professionnels pour découvrir le monde
de l'entreprise c'est le principe du
speed dating des métiers 120 élèves de
3e et 4e du territoire ont pu à
découvrir ce matin à trappes 20 métiers
et des jeunes qui ont souvent du mal à
trouver leur orientation
enfin la fête des amoureux approche et
si vous avez prévu de célébrer la saint
valentin avec votre moitié nous vous
donnons quelques idées des idées de
sorties et de cadeaux mais aussi une
soirée originale elle est à découvrir
dans le coup de coeur culture de la
semaine et des invités également en
plateau nous présenterons la conférence
débat l'enfant et les écrans qui se
tient à montigny le bretonneux et nous
aurons également sur ce plateau nicolas
u qui sera candidat aux municipales de
2020 à dans la ville des
clayes-sous-bois mais avant de
développer ses titres deux personnes
placées en garde à vue ce matin par la
sous direction antiterroriste deux
individus de 23 et 36 ans interpellée
dans le cadre de l' enquête sur
l'assassinât du couple de policiers à
magnanville en 2016 et jessica schneider
et jean baptiste salvin avait été tué au
couteau devant leur fils de trois ans
par un homme radicaliser l es deux
personnes arrêtées connu des services de
police sont soupçonnés d'avoir donné les
noms et adresses des victimes est les
autres suspects dans cette affaire ont
été relâchés deux hommes ont déjà mené
en ont déjà été mis en examen pour
complicité est d'assassinât le
déploiement de la fibre optique se
poursuit dans les yvelines à côté du
syndicat mixte du conseil départemental
et de l'opérateur sfr orange qui compte
achevé son déploiement dans six cent
mille foyers focus sur les communes de
saint quentin en
line avec nicolas landry la fibre
optique pour tous en 2021 sur saint
quentin en yvelines c'est l'objectif de
l'opérateur orange les opérations
démarrent cette année pour avoir une
couverture totale sur la verrière et
trappe d'ici à deux ans situation
identique à villepreux avec l'ensemble
des foyers fibrés en 2021
le réseau fibre est quasiment cinq fois
plus petit que le réseau cuivre au point
de vue sur phase d'installation qui
permet enfin de compte d'alimenter une
zone jusqu'à 20 kilomètres autour les
fibres qui vont toucher les clients vont
être capable d'être utilisé par tous les
opérateurs qui le souhaitent et vont
pouvoir les clients vont donc pouvoir
reprendre l'opérateur qui souhaite pour
pouvoir avoir les services qu'ils
souhaitent aussi elancourt plaisir
maurepas et voisins le bretonneux toutes
ces communes bénéficient déjà de la
fibre optique sfr s'est occupé à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines uniquement de
la ville de montigny le bretonneux avec
la possibilité pour les clients de
savoir s'ils peuvent bénéficier de cette
technologie
alors nous avons différents sites
d'information sur internet que vous
pouvez consulter et qui vous indiquent
que la fibre et dans votre ville la
fibre et dans votre quartier la fibre
est dans votre rue le dispositif sera
installé à la fin de l'année à
guyancourt magny les hameaux et
coignières pour les clayes-sous-bois ce
sera en 2020 actuellement 400 mille
logements sont éligibles à la fibre
optique dans les yvelines le numérique
qui ne cesse de se développer on vient
de le voir sur les réseaux mais c'est
aussi le cas sur écran nombreux sont ces
écrans qui nous entourent télévision
ordinateur à tablettes ou encore
smartphones que l'on utilise de plus en
plus jeunes selon une dernière étude de
l'arcep autorité de régulation 93% des
12 17 ans sont équipés d'un smartphone
pour les plus jeunes les tablettes sont
de plus en plus présente également dans
l'apprentissage à l'école alors quelles
conséquences pour nos enfants comment se
positionner en tant que parents et
questions posées lors d'une conférence
débat qui se tient ce vendredi à la
salle jacques brel à montigny le
bretonneux et pour en parler à une
invitée manuela afonso cancel mon soir
on sera peut être la présidente de la
pec montigny-le-bretonneux qui organise
cette conférence paix pour parents
d'élèves de l'enseignement
publiques déjà en préambule qu'est ce
que la paix quelles sont ses missions
alors la pub est une comme vous venez de
dire une fédération de représentants de
parents d'élèves dont je suis présidente
d'association sur la ville de montigny
le bretonneux
notre rôle est principalement
d'accompagner les enseignants les
parents et les élèves le tout dans le
bien-être de l'élève et de sa scolarité
un mot sur l'antenne présenta à montigny
le bretonneux beaucoup de parents qui en
font partie
alors nous sommes une petite association
une quinzaine d'adhérents m'aider à ceux
des parents très motivé une équipe très
soudée et on commence à mettre en place
beaucoup de projets afin de soutenir et
de porter la voix des parents de notre
ville et sur les projets c'est ce type
d'actions par exemple comme une comme
cette conférence débat cette conférence
est la première le la première d'une
série d'événements les autres ne seront
pas aussi énorme que celui ci mais on
parle pour le coup d'un sujet qui nous
tient à coeur et qui est un fonds dans
le dans le dans l'actualité du moment
sur saint quentin en yvelines qui est le
numérique à l'école et les conséquences
que cela peut avoir sur le développement
cérébral de l'enfant on a vu la fiche
apparaître à l'écran donc on l'a dit une
conférence débat qui est au programme ce
vendredi à 19h30 à la salle jacques-brel
de montigny le bretonneux
pourquoi consacrer ce rendez-vous vous
l'aï dit c'est une thématique actuelle
cette thématique des écrans des
conséquences que peuvent avoir les
écrans sur les enfants alors tout à fait
c'est une thématique très actuelle
autant au niveau national qu'au niveau
local la ville de montigny le bretonneux
nous a largement soutenu dans
l'élaboration de ce projet est également
au niveau national comme je vous le
disais c'est un sujet qui tient
énormément à coeur aux enseignants dû à
un changement assez significatif du
comportement des élèves en classe et
également de la part des parents qui ne
savent plus vraiment comment s'y prendre
vis-à-vis de leur enfant qui devient de
plus en plus dépendants de tout type
d'écran en passant principalement par le
téléphone et la tablette dans cette
thématique également d'actualité avec ce
développement du numérique ici à saint
quentin en yvelines un effort qui est
apportée sur l'essor des tablettes
à l'école on va vers plus de numérique
ça c'est indéniable avec des angles et
écran vous le disiez aussi de tout aussi
présents dans la sphère privée
les enfants qui jouent aux jeux vidéo
voilà pour le cliché vous placez comment
en tant que maman est ce que vous êtes
inquiète sur sur ce sujet alors entendre
moment il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
particulière vis-à-vis du scolaire dans
le sens où nos enfants vont évoluer
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans un
monde très numérique donc autant qu'ils
soient formés dès l'école cependant en
tant que maman à la maison je pense
qu'il est très important d'informer et
surtout d'accompagner ses enfants dans
l'apprentissage de ces outils qui
peuvent devenir des pièges on le voit
assez bien avec les thématiques du
harcèlement à l'école avec les
thématiques de de l'enfant qui
décrochent parce que parce que décrocher
de la réalité voilà je pense qu'il est
le rôle du parent d'accompagner son
enfant est de faire en sorte qu'il soit
instruit le mieux possible sur ce sujet
l'outil du numérique à l'école vous le
disiez ça peut aussi aider à
sensibiliser sur l'e-réputation qui a un
thème aussi d'actualité un thème
important tout à fait très important il
d'ailleurs à ce sujet il y à une cellule
qui a été mise en place par par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
concernant le harcèlement et la crise de
l'e-réputation ce principalement dans
les collèges et les lycées où cet effet
peut être dévastateur non ce sera
d'ailleurs l'un des angles de cette
conférence comment se positionner en
tant que parent il ya aussi le côté
médical une neuro pédiatre de l'hôpital
poincaré de garches sera présente pour
expliquer les les conséquences sur sur
la santé des enfants
alors tout à fait c'est le docteur
laisse les sirops qui officie à
l'hôpital de garches dans le 92 qui est
neuro pédiatre spécialisé dans les
troubles de l'apprentissage de l'enfant
elle sera là principalement pour
présenter les résultats des dernières
recherches
effectuée sur le sujet est également
dispensé tout les conseils des sociétés
de pédiatrie et ensuite bien sûr
répondre aux questions des parents c'est
pourquoi on en fait une conférence débat
est simplement et pas simplement une
conférence comme il dit et tout à
l'heure les objectifs c'est pas
forcément de dire sais c'est mal le
numérique au contraire on va vers plus
de numerix et de d'informer d'informer
ses parents tout à fait l'objectif
premier n'est pas de prendre une
position ferme sur le numérique c'est de
renseigner et de faire en sorte que
l'accompagnement de l'enfant et du
parent se fasse de la manière la plus
sereine possible sur la forme conférence
débat aussi vous vous le disiez donc une
intervention de la neuro pédiatre qui
sera suivie d'une discussion
en fait on va commencer par présenter la
réalité médicale de ce sujet et très
vite on va essayer d'enclencher un
système de questions réponses pour
pouvoir développer et ouvrir surtout
libéré la parole et les questionnements
qui peuvent se poser une question le
plus pratique pour terminer l'entrée est
libre mais les places sont limitées il
faut réserver à l'avancé
oui en effet nous avons un nombre limité
de places car la salle jacques brel
n'est pas extensible à l'infini
du coup nous avons mis en place un
module de réservation par billetterie en
ligne accessible sur le site de l'apec
monsigny 78 ch actuellement
merci et est également je peux inscrire
moi même des personnes je vous invite à
me contacter au numéro disponible sur le
site internet
conférence débat l'enfant et et les
écrans au programme ce vendredi à partir
de 19h30 à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux merci à manuel
afonso cancel merci à avec nos
présidents de la paix
montigny le bretonneux éducation
toujours dans l'actualité du jour
environ à 90 % des professeurs du
collège youri-gagarine attrape étaient
en grève ce mardi accompagnés de parents
d'élèves ils se sont rassemblés ce matin
devant les grilles de l'établissement
classé en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
renforcer ces enseignants souhaitent
alerter sur une situation qu'ils jugent
inquiétante la baisse de la dotation
horaire alloués au collège pour l'année
scolaire 2010 9 2020 cette diminution
n'assurerait pas des conditions sereines
de travail et d'apprentissage pour les
élèves
explications au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude au lieu d'avoir six cent
soixante dix heures pour parler
technique 510 heures d'enseignement on
passe à six ans
cinquante heures seulement donc on perd
une vingtaine d'heures sur
l'établissement ce qui fait qu'on est
obligé de supprimer des dispositifs ou
alors de supprimer une classe donc ce
sera pour la rentrée prochaine pour
l'année prochaine on sera obligé de swat
faire disparaître tous les dispositifs d
aide pour les élèves
donc on pourra plus assurer donc tout le
soutien scolaire tout le
l'accompagnement personnalisé qu'en
données aux élèves soit on supprime une
classe de 5e donc on a un choix à faire
et qu'on ne peut pas assumer nous en
tant qu'enseignants et les professeurs
veulent qu la dotation horaire soit
revue à la hausse par leur
administration qui n'ont pas rencontré à
ce jour et demain une mobilisation et
syndicales avec d'autres établissements
est prévu devant les locaux
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
à guyancourt
du côté des élèves difficile de savoir
ce que l'on veut faire quand on est en
classe de troisième ce mardi matin 120
collégiens des environs ont rencontré à
des professionnels lors d'un speed
dating des métiers organisé par le club
fasse yvelines une quatrième édition sur
laquelle reviennent aurélie rose et
manon varaldo second qui signifie le
changement d'ateliers pour les
collégiens sous forme de speed dating
avec une rotation toutes les 20 minutes
les élèves découvrent trois métiers
différents
l'objectif pendant ces 20 minutes baas
et des échanges sur les parcours de
métiers les formations pour accéder à
ces métiers et surtout les activités
quotidienne de ces métiers riz pour que
les élèves pourrait se poser des
questions les élèves de 4e commencent
leurs réflexions sur leur orientation
ils sont eux aussi présents durant cette
matinée accompagné des troisièmes il
nous explique nous faire une parle un
peu de ce qui se passe dans cette
entreprise ça nous permet de savoir en
savoir plus sur certains métiers métiers
de service de l'industrie ou encore du
btp les professionnels expliquent leur
parcours aux élèves et leur font
découvrir de nouveaux secteurs dans les
métiers du transport il ya du travail a
pas de chômage que c'est vraiment des
secteurs d'activité d'avenir avec des
métiers qui évolue énormément avec des
technologies des logiciels qui évoluent
sur place également une école de
commerce qui ouvre en octobre 2019 sur
le territoire l'occasion pour les élèves
de découvrir les formations proposées
quand on demande aux jeunes qu est-ce
que quelqu'un comme métier dans la
sphère sportive
on nous parle de professeur de sport on
nous parle de coach sportif dont le
thème était très opérationnelle sans
pour autant savoir qu' il ya tout un
écosystème qui tourne autour du sport
business donc sur des métiers liés au
secteur de la communication du marketing
du management on a une réelle charge de
travail est vraiment matière à
renseigner les gens sur tous ces métiers
là une connaissance sur les métiers des
réponses à leurs questions qui
permettront aux collégiens de faire pour
le mois de mai leur demande
d'affectation se chiffre à présent 10,7
en moyenne 10,7 mois de vie en bonne
santé en moins pour les franciliens
c'est le bilan de la dernière étude de
bruitparif sur les nuisances sonores
près de 90 % des franciliens sont
impactées à cause essentiellement du
trafic et du trafic routier et
ferroviaire conséquences sur la santé
cela va de simples difficultés de
concentration à des troubles du sommeil
voire des troubles cardiovasculaires
dans les yvelines les nuisances viennent
particulièrement de l'a13 et de la n10
et villes principalement concerné la
verrière bordée par la nationale 10 et
les lignes n ai eu du transilien
et puisqu'on parle de la nationale 10 un
enfant de huit ans a été percuté par une
voiture hier en fin d'après midi sur
l'axé routier au niveau de trappes
le véhicule circulait en direction de
paris le
gravement blessé a été transféré vers un
hôpital parisien en état d'urgence
absolue ses jours ne seraient toutefois
pas en danger
elles ne sont programmés que l'an
prochain les élections municipales sont
déjà dans la tête cette discipline on a
certains maires ont annoncé à la volonté
de se représenter ou pas est des
candidats se déclarent c'est votre cas
nicolas hulot soir bonsoir
vous êtes un élu d'opposition aux
clayes-sous-bois dans l'opposition
également à saint quentin en yvelines et
vous serez candidat aux clayes-sous-bois
l'année prochaine en 2020 une première
question toute simple pourquoi être
candidat alors au delà de ma candidature
c'est surtout un mouvement que j'ai
voulu initier un mouvement qui
permettent aux clés siens mes
concitoyens en fait de pouvoir reprendre
la parole une parole qui est quelque peu
confisqué depuis quelques années
l'équipe municipale en place est là
depuis 18 ans les projets des décisions
se font sans que les chrétiens
aujourd'hui ne soit réellement associés
aux décisions et au delà de cette
candidature c'est réellement la volonté
de créer un mouvement citoyen un
mouvement qui puissent et permettent aux
chrétiens de partager un projet que nous
présenterons je le souhaite ardemment
lors des élections municipales de mars
2020 or l'année dernière lors d'une
émission du café politique vous annoncez
votre ralliement au mouvement génération
mené par un benoît hamon est ce que ça
pourrait se faire sous cette étiquette 7
cette candidature
aujourd'hui c'est ce n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour aujourd'hui c'est une alliance
citoyenne nous créons d'ailleurs une
association à cette fin une association
qui voit le jour enfin qui verra le jour
ces prochains jours justement
et à cette occasion nous allons nous
mettre en place des rencontres
citoyennes mensuel qui commence dès ce
samedi afin d'inviter tous les chrétiens
à venir partager le bilan de ce
qu'ils ont pu constater sur la ville et
surtout les attendus qu'ils en
ressortent pour les années à venir
au delà d'un étiquetage ou d'un appareil
politique qui se mettrait les uns les
autres à discuter d'un projet commun ou
en tout cas de distribuer les rôles
notre idée mon idée est l'idée de mes
collègues et des citoyens qui nous ont
déjà rejoints
c'est évidemment de partager un projet
qui fédère l'ensemble des chrétiens et
pas uniquement des petites entités d'un
tiroir donner la parole aux clés siens
alors d'ailleurs sauf grande surprise la
mer udi à véronique côté millard ne se
représentera pas elle qui est à la tête
de la commune depuis 2001 quel regard
vous portez sur sur scène plusieurs
plusieurs années de mandat un regard
évidemment un peu critique notamment au
regard de de l'urbanisme qui a été le
sien et qui a été celui de son équipe
ces dernières années une new york
bannissement peu galopant qui qu'il n'a
pas eu pour effets escomptés
justement ce qui était envisagé au
départ c'est de garder une population un
peu dynamiques sur la ville puisque nous
sommes même en perte de population sur
la commune et qui a surtout donné aux
promoteurs la possibilité de créer et de
réaliser des logements par eux même sens
que la puissance publique n'ait son mot
à dire réel et je pense que là c'est un
un des sujets sur lequel il faudra
vraiment se pencher sur les années à
venir c'est et c'est ce que nous
demandons nous depuis des années
maintenant c'est de nous donner et c'est
que ce que nous proposons nous chrétiens
de faire de proposer un projet de ville
à hauteur de 15 ans ou 20 ans on ne peut
pas réaliser aujourd'hui des projets
qu'ils soient juste limité dans le temps
à une mandature
il faut qu'il y ait vraiment une vision
sur le long terme c'est ce que je
regrette aujourd'hui de la part de la
mère des claies sortante et de son
équipe
aussi il est possible aujourd'hui ok se
voit aujourd'hui je pense évidemment
qu'une alternance est possible de
nombreux chrétiens aujourd'hui sont
mécontents sur pas mal de sujets je vous
ai exprimé tout à l'heure la question
d'urbanisme
il y a aussi le respect de
l'environnement du cadre de vie
je donne juste pour preuve le fait
qu'aujourd'hui un des seul poumon vert
qui reste en plein coeur de ville
sept mille mètres carrés sont voués à la
démolition et la disparition du fait de
la volonté de la mère et de son équipe
l'occasion de solidarité les questions
de convivialité notamment avec la
redynamisation de notre centre-ville
sont des sujets très prégnant auprès des
chrétiens et c'est évidemment ce sur
quoi aujourd'hui il me semble important
de travailler et qui à mon sens peuvent
permettre une alternance prochaine donc
les thématiques importantes vous disiez
redonner la parole aux clés sien
c'est-à-dire plus de démocratie
participative c'est un thème qui est qui
revient souvent en ce moment mais c'est
un thème dont on parle mais dont on voit
peu l'action derrière moi le sujet est
justement de remettre cette question au
goût du jour et au lieu de
montrer une nouvelle fois une image nos
concitoyens qui verrait une nouvelle
fois leurs élus devenir que à leur
encontre de moi ou trois mois avant les
élections
pour ma part le chose doit se faire
différemment autrement maintenant elle
doit se faire en prenant en
considération leurs attentes dès à
présent et c'est pour ça que la
démocratie participative moi je m'y
attelle dès maintenant avec ces
rencontres mensuelles que nous mettons
en place dès samedi prochain
et puis aussi ses cahiers de
contribution nous mettons des canettes
contribution que nous disposons dans
certains endroits de la ville afin que
les chrétiens puissent dès à présent
nous apporter leurs remarques et
apporter leurs idées pour qu'on puisse
partager un projet commun et donc les
élections municipales je leur rappelle
qu'ils sont programmées l'an prochain
merci à nicolas d'être passé sur ce
plateau vous serez candidats pour ces
élections municipales aux
clayes-sous-bois vous êtes actuellement
élu d'opposition dans cette commune
merci à j - 2 avant la saint-valentin
savez-vous déjà ce que vous ferez ce
jeudi si vous n'avez pas encore d'idée
pas de panique notre journaliste michael
almy doro propose trois suggestions dans
les yvelines regarder ce jeudi 14
février les yvelines seront placés en
vigilance orange pour fêter la saint
valentin
certains établissements proposent des
prestations spéciales pour accueillir
les amoureux à versailles le trianon
palace a vu grand et propose différents
package dont un à partir de 500 euros un
prix qui comprend notamment une chambre
luxueuse décorée pour l'occasion dans ce
package là et donc inclut aussi un coeur
croquant des dix benghanem donc c'est un
coeur en chocolat blanc fournis et garni
de confiserie aussi tout fait maison
tout comme le coeur et vous avez bien
évidemment le lit parsemé de fleurs de
rose de pétales de roses pour pouvoir
justement rester dans le cadre intime et
feutrée de l'hôtel
l'hôtel propose également aux clients
des cocktails spéciaux à base d'alcool
de fruits rouges de liqueur de chocolat
ou de fruits de la passion des
ingrédients choisis pour créer une
ambiance romantique dans ce lieu datant
de 1910 nous avons décidé de filippo a
décidé de
créer un dôme de glaçons pour pouvoir
mettre en avant aussi les fruits en
entier qui sont mis en valeur aussi dans
le cocktail
si vous voulez déclarer votre flamme
dans un lieu historique datant du xiiie
siècle château de villiers le mahieu
organise un repas spécial saint valentin
le 14 février au soir dans ses rangs par
les propriétaires proposent également
aux clients de passer un week-end dans
l'une des 98 chambres du site à partir
de 349 euros
au programme séances de spa pour les
couples avec massage en duo et activités
en plein air sur les 22 hectares du site
beaucoup d'activités sont bien sûr à
votre disposition vous avez des vélos
vous les empreintes et lorsque vous le
souhaitez des trottinettes mais
également afin de passer un bon week end
en amoureux des barques puisque nous
avons la chance ici au château de
villiers le mahieu d'avoir des douves en
eau si vous êtes d'humeur rock casanière
est plutôt ambiance coin du feu la ferme
de grignon situé à côté de plaisir
propose pour la première fois cette
année dé coffret spécial saint valentin
entre 15 et 40 euros
cette boîte gourmande a été imaginé
pendant plusieurs semaines pour rendre
l'atmosphère chaleureuse
c'est romantique mais aussi corps est
vrai dire un petit peu champêtre
donc non il y en a un qui va être plus
décidé à faire un petit repas avec un
plat cuisiné une terrine en entrée
quelque chose comme ça et après c'est
plus sur le faire un cadeau
la petite terrine un petit billet
des choses comme ça dans un palace dans
un château ou bien chez soi le plus
important reste avant tout de raviver la
flamme pendant une soirée est peut-être
plus et pour la saint valentin après le
restaurant c'est aussi l'occasion
d'aller voir un spectacle bonsoir
mélanie poker à magny les hameaux on
joue la carte du sexy et du glamour la
maison de l'environnement la sacem à une
effeuilleuse eh oui valentina at-elle ps
vous entraîne dans un cabaret burlesque
de l'effeuillage un divertissement qui
même gabarit coquin et comédies légères
alors lancé dans les cabarets parisiens
à la fin du 19e siècle style s'est
exportée aux états unis pour donner les
fameuses pin up pour ce jeudi quête en
février le burlesque club décortique les
façades du mouvement un petit extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas je
[Musique]
blâmant mais aussi l'humour et oui elles
sont cinq sur scène cinq artistes
effeuilleuses cannelle doubleclick
mamzelle prunty mara de nude et rosa
d'elle c'est la vie et sucre d'orge l
art elle alterne des numéros poétiques
drôles et parfois totalement kitsch et
complètement assumé la place est laissée
aux rétro à l'humour au comique et la
soirée continuera après le spectacle
puisque un buffet spécial saint valentin
concocté par les amis de l'estaminet est
prévue merci mélanie dans un instant
vous retrouve aux manettes du 7-8
culture je vous propose tout de même
avant de refermer ce journal on va
rester à la maison de l'environnement de
magny les hameaux qui a vibré samedi
soir pour la première fois elle
accueillait le tremplin des voix une
vingtaine de candidats s'est affrontés
sur scène face à un jury et au public
qui pouvait voter pour ses favoris
retour avec marylène iapichino ce soir
il en reste plus que 21 21 candidats
coachée par l'équipe de la voix en scène
pour assurer la meilleure prestation
possible et se faire plaisir pour me
donner encore des nouvelles de nouveaux
objectifs en fait donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas en fait tout simplement
le but c'est de donner une chance à des
gens qui disent qu'ils tâtonnent qui
savent pas forcément s'y sont faits pour
ça s'ils ont envie de faire ça jusqu'au
bout de leur vie
et on est mis face à des professionnels
en plus des trois catégories jugés par
des professionnels le public avait aussi
sa voix a donné pour désigner son
chouchou de la soirée le concert était
diffusé sur internet message des votes
ont pu dépasser les frontières de magny
les hameaux
en tout les styles représentés
ainsi que tous les âges
[Musique]
à 9 ans et demi ça n'aille la plus jeune
de la compétition pour l'encourager son
équipe de foot lui a fait la surprise de
lui envoyer un message
[Musique]
cinq heures de show qui ont récompensé
quatre artistes dont le rappeur et nîmes
d'un curetage dans la catégorie auteur
compositeur interprète nos droits et nos
devoirs
on nous dit que l'homme est libre de ses
choix sauf on oublie précisé que seul
l'argent est roi mais vous en souvenez
sans doute qu'ils retapent nous avons
reçu au début du mois de janvier c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi le cetud journal et ses reportages
c'est à revoir bien sûr sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]